Okay. We are recording on here and just make sure we're sharing. Welcome to our Zoom call for 2019, the day before Valentine's day. So hopefully you guys have got your Valentine something nice to share with them and tell them that they're special.
So today's Zoom call we had a much questions coming so let's jump right to the questions and we'll open it up for questions. Here was one of the first questions. How much protein per meal or per day is required to activate muscle building.
Listen to something that said you need 30 grams of protein per meal to build muscle. I may have got that wrong so could you please clarify.
The most important thing about building a muscle is not so much the amount of protein that you take in but it's the amount of muscle building stimulation that a person does.
Be that you could eat 100 grams of protein at every meal and all you do is sit on the couch all day or lie in bed all day. You're not going to build muscle or you could eat all carbohydrates and you could lift weights and you'll build muscle.
So if you're activating muscle in your body, meaning you are exercising of some sort or lifting weights, then you will build muscle. Now if you're going to be exercising and lifting weights and you want to build muscle faster, it would be better if you ate a little bit more protein.
Then if you were just completely eating carbohydrates, but in truth, you could eat solid carbohydrates, as long as you were exercising, you'll still build muscle because you'll convert those carbohydrates into protein and you build muscle.
So the most important thing about keeping away from cakexia, that is muscle loss, and trying to build muscle is to activate muscle, meaning you have to lift weights, you have to exercise, whatever exercise you have to contract muscles.
So if you're contracting muscles, if you're contracting it against another force, that is weightlifting or you know some sort of exercise, then you are going to help build that muscle.
But in general, for a person with cancer, how much protein should they be eating? Well, that brings us back to the question of if a person has cancer and their cancer is is feeding off of glutamate and methionate glutamate and methionate.
So it's feeding off of redo acids, those people want to be on a lower protein diet, so it isn't recommended that they're counting their grams of protein and trying to get the protein into their diet.
Cancer is mainly glycolytic, meaning that cancer is mainly being fed off of sources of sugar carbohydrates and they are okay to eat protein, well then they can be eating protein.
Again, I wouldn't necessarily be counting my grams of protein. So it depends on what the feeding source of your cancer at this time is.
But again, if I was told to eat a low protein diet where you're not eating a lot of meat, you're getting protein in your vegetables, I wouldn't be counting my grams of protein.
I would be trusting in the amount of protein that I'm getting in my vegetation is fine. I would just work on setting up a muscle milling exercise by doing some weights or something like that.
And again, you could start with low weights. It's not like you have to be lifting, you know, doing 30 pound curls, but if you're a bigger person doing 30 pound curls wouldn't necessarily be a bad thing.
So, but starting small with five pound weights or two pound weights if you have to, depends on where your starting point is.
That's going to be the most important thing. So don't worry about counting the grams of protein.
I'm worried about the exercise that you're doing.
Next question, wondering what is better for cancer? Ozone therapy or hyperbaric oxygen?
Well, the answer to that question depends on the person and depends on the person that you're asking, I guess, because it's a matter of opinion.
So my opinion is that for most cancers, you are better off doing hyperbaric oxygen therapy to help kill the cancer than ozone therapy.
Now, the thought that ozone therapy as a source of oxygen really isn't really true. Well, ozone is oxygen, right? Well, ozone is O3 and what really helps ozone therapy work is that O3 is relatively unstable.
That gives off one of its electrons to typically biotoxin. So ozone therapy really shines and killing biotoxins really shines with light. Now, there's multiple ways a person could get ozone therapy.
If you inject ozone right into the tissue and that can help stimulate an immune reaction similar to prolo therapy, prolotherapy, where it increases the
fluid production, it can help certain joints. And I highly recommend that if a person has a really bad joint before they go and they do joint replacement therapy, do ozone therapy.
We've had some patients experiment with ozone injected right into the tumor.
Firstly, we haven't seen really good success with that really no success with that. But I know that is a therapy.
Ozone therapy, Ozoneating blood, there's a there's a type of IV therapy that you can put ozone, Ozoneate the blood.
That can have some benefit. I think that shines more with lime, treaty lime and mold issues that it does so much with cancer. I know that there's some cancer clinics in Mexico that do do that.
I'm not really convinced that that's the best therapy for cancer.
And then the benefit of hyperbaric oxygen is you're increasing the oxygenation of the tissue. And if you can oxygenate a cancer, you can really help kill that cancer because cancer tends to grow better.
That's called the Warburg effect in a state of hypoxia. It stimulates lactic acid, feed it in its feeds off of lactic acid in a hypoxic state. So if you can increase oxygen to the cancer, you could help push that pathway in the other direction and slow down the girls of the cancer.
So if I had to choose between two, should I do ozone therapy, I should do hyperbaric therapy, I do hyperbaric. The pros and cons go a little bit deeper than that because one of the kind of a kind of hyperbaric as you order all the studies with hyperbaric oxygen and cancer have been very positive.
But the negative of it is all the studies are done where a person's doing hyperbaric, at least five, you know, usually five days a week. So our hyperbaric unit in our office gets very underused simply because most our patients are not local.
So, you know, it's not going to really be beneficial for somebody to come on a two day and do two days versus a hyperbaric oxygen, and then they go home and they don't do it anymore. There's not a huge benefit there.
Can it stimulate the start of a detox detoxification of their body? Sure. So there can be some benefit there, but it's not going to be really cancer killing doing two days of hyperbaric oxygen.
So hyperbaric oxygen, if there is a downside to it, the downside is that you really need to do it on a very regular basis, doing it daily would be best.
Hyperbaric oxygen also shines not just with cancer with brain issues, fantastic for Alzheimer's Parkinson's issues, it's fantastic for Lyme patients with any kind of brain fog with any kind of inflammation in their brain, brain cancers, it's a fantastic tool.
So hyperbaric oxygen is a very big positive. I wish they were really inexpensive, but people could have them in their house that would be the best use of that.
But if I had to choose between the two, I would choose hyperbaric for sure.
The next question is kind of long and I'm only going to be able to answer part of this question. So you know who you are who asked that in the second half of it really warrants a call with Angie and she can help you figure out the answers to see that as I go through this.
After two and a half years of eliminating gluten dairy and soy, still having a lot of bloated and gas in abdominal inflammation, what is the cause?
Well, when a person has these issues, okay, I've eliminated some node allergies in my body and I'm still food allergies, I'm still having a lot of gut inflammation, what could be the cause.
That's what we typically recommend to do a Syrex test. A Syrex test is a brand, it's a lab itself Syrex labs, they have what's called an array 10, the array 10 is what measures a whole bunch of different foods.
And I just pulled this off the internet, this is actually from the array 4, but array 10 measures, you get like six pages of this, because there's 300 different foods that are measured in an array 10.
And you see things that are in the green, which are the normal range in the yellow, which are abnormal in the red, which are way out of range.
So in this case, this person, this is taking off the internet, KC, KC is the protein in dairy, so this person is in the yellow for KC, if this was my patient, I'd say you have to go off of everything that's in the yellow in the red range here.
So this person is very high in the way protein, so they shouldn't be taking anything with way protein, they shouldn't be taking anything with oats, coffee, and with these things out here.
But then you could read it a little deeper, so this is measuring KC, alpha and beta KC, and it's high.
Well, you could go even deeper, which this question begs us to says, I realize diet environment, epigenetics, and mutations, your genetics, play a role in what's going in and out of remission for the cancer.
But at the moment, relatively increased recurrence, so I decided to do a Cyrex test, or a 10, the results where antibody formation to four foods, actually, a few more pumpkin chia seeds, Brazil nuts, pineapple, marmalade, pepper, diet chains, family, and sunflower seeds.
So those are this person's biggest things, this is not this person's reading, obviously, their lab.
But those are the things that came up major here. But then you see this person has the question that in parentheses, there's no cross reactive information was received on pumpkin and chia nuts.
The cross reactive foods to Brazil nuts were these things, so what this person is asking is when we get a Cyrex test back like this.
Cyrex gives you the data on all these diff every single thing tested and every single thing tested many of them have what are called cross reactive foods.
So understand this test is a test for do you have antibodies to certain foods and typically it's a peptide of that food.
Acid is the protein in in dairy, so this this person does not react to has no reaction to cow's milk itself, but the protein in cow's milk they're reacting to.
The way protein, which is different than the case scene protein in cow's milk they're reacting to also so it's breaking it down instead of just looking do you have a cow's milk allergy and if that's all the test if someone did a different test and that's all the test measured you think you'd be safe on that.
But this shows that no you are actually reactive to different components of that so in this case your this person's reacted to the case scene in the way protein.
Just just as much person could react to chocolate milk versus regular milk as you can see that this test measures and the array can actually measures 300 plus different things so it gets very detailed into different possible things that a person's reacted to.
So who would do it array 10 exactly somebody who wrote this question here still having issues maybe got issues so it's really easy to say you should do it array 10 to someone who is having got symptoms like this person even after eliminating some major causes of got issues gluten dairy and sewing.
But another person that should do it array 10 is someone who maybe they don't have any got issues but their Lyme disease keeps flaring up their mold keeps flaring up their cancer goes out of remission and starts starts growing again what could cause that an immune reaction of some something from something could cause that.
So what is that what could that be from what certainly could be from something you're eating so here's a person that's been stayed off and I know this patient so they're really, really rigid they're really, really good on their diet so when they say they've been stayed off of gluten dairy and soy they've been stayed off that those things.
And if that is true then why are they reacted to these other things well when you have a damage got.
When you have a damage got you things get through the barrier so your your gut wall are your epithelial cells and those epithelial cells I have to have a tight junction in the only thing that's supposed to get through that are small little particles of the food the proteins.
Proteins the carbohydrates of those foods that are supposed to break down via digestion in the stomach and in the intestinal tract.
If you have a damaged gut wall that border is broken so larger particles are getting through before they're completely digested meaning broken down to small little amino acids instead of the giant proteins.
So the proteins and peptides sections of proteins of food are getting across the gut wall much larger pieces that ever should and your immune system recognizes them as enemies because they shouldn't be in the bloodstream and you start to create antibodies against them.
And then when you're exposed to that food because you have antibodies against it you create this inflammatory reaction in it further damages the gut.
And you end up with an inflammatory reaction so if a person has cancer in their immune system has been doing really good for a period of time knocking that cancer down and they have a damage got wall and they have inflammation to a food like this person's case here.
And they're still eating Brazil that's pumpkin seeds which I see it's bromelain night chains.
They got this ramped up inflammation now they have less ability to fight the cancer the cancer continues to grow or takes off out of remission again because their immune system is taken up causing the inflammation from the antibodies.
Integent antibody reaction to the foods that they're eating.
So should a person do it array 10 who should do it array 10 someone who has constant got issues that we can't seem to figure out or a person who moves out of remission of their cancer starts growing and we can't figure out why that's where we recommend an array 10.
Now somebody asked the question is the 23 me test we did with you better or equivalent to the Syrex test it's it's not the same you're not comparing apples to apples here the 23 me test is a genetic test this the Syrex is measuring do I have antibodies to foods that I'm eating.
So they're not the same they're not the same thing you can get up at all the same.
So what does not replace the other they're measuring two different things.
So this is measuring do I have antibodies to different foods that I've eaten and that this goes even deeper because we see a picture like this and they should stay off of dairy after looking at this picture.
This picture and all sources of dairy even way protein after looking at this picture.
But also you can look up Syrex gives us another sheet on just about every one of these that explains what KC is it explains what way protein is and it says shows the other cross reactants.
So there are cross reactants to way protein and I didn't pull up any of those sheets here that are completely different than a way protein because they look similar molecularly.
So there can be molecular mimics two way protein that a person could react to something else that is that is on that list of molecular mimic and that's what this person that asked this question because obviously they went over there.
So Brazil nuts the cross reactive foods or molecular mimics are cashews hazelnuts pistachios and almonds.
The first thing when I go over an array 10 is I say you have to stay away from these things first so let's start with those and then they stay away from those and three weeks later we talk and like oh my gosh my symptoms are so much better I feel so much better or they're a little bit better but not the best okay now we're going to go into the cross reactive list.
So it's a great job staying away from Brazil nuts pineapple bromelain pepper die chain family and sunflower seeds but you're still having problems we have to look at the cross reacted foods too.
Now you're going to stay away from also cashews hazelnuts pistachios almonds the carrot family carrots parsley celery dill federal so it gets kind of complicated and it makes people very unhappy because it does limit their diet.
So you have to calm down the inflammation that's in the gut you have to calm down the inflammation so the gut is these stayed away from these things is not a forever thing it's we got to get the inflammation down to heal the gut is if you don't heal the gut then you're just you're just constantly causing inflammation so
10 and I'm not going to go into all these questions because literally it's an hour long conversation to talk about what can we substitute now what can we do digging a little bit deeper this gets very complicated so but this can be the answer doing it or a 10 could be the answer to what a person's problems are so this is a great test.
The problem is it it gives people some bad news sometimes because it can really limit their diet so a person's in caccia you can't really do this because they have to be eating some food but we have to look at possible cross reactants and sometimes people are really happy with me when we look at these pictures but it's really necessary so it's a great test to do.
So I always tell people we're always good we're going to go off all the yellows and reds and understand there's about six to eight pages of this and we look at a rate 10 and then we're going to see how we're doing and then we're going to look at cross reactants and we're going to go one by one on the cross reactants and start eliminating those things and that's what it starts to really get complicated this is a blood test we have these available in the office we send out the kit.
With the requisition form you go get a local blood draw takes about a week or so to get this test back and then we can go over it but it can really tell you some stories of why you have problems i used to see a lot of autoimmune patients number of years ago we used to run this test boy it just answered all the questions that they had and we can really solve some problems that nobody else could figure out so it's a great test to do we do this a lot in our office.
Another question came in said it then seems we should still do the Syrex if there can be some hidden issues with foods yes or does it a ET tested suffice no there isn't any other testing that would suffice kinesiology does not touch these little pieces I don't have test kits for the 300 different things that would test positive.
So you really need to run the lab there's just no substitute for it and don't the people who I would say don't do this would be people who really are going to discipline themselves to follow.
Through with what the outcome shows so you're just going to be honest with yourself if you're like hey change my diet any who then don't spend the money to do the test but people that really want to get deeper and see either why their cancer started to grow again or why.
There got hasn't calmed down or why their headaches don't go away or why they're autoimmune issue their rashes don't go away or there are arthritis continues to flare then this is an extremely valuable test so we highly recommend it so if it's something that you are interested in I would.
Contact the office and let us know set up a time that we can talk or you can talk with Michelle or Ann about this and we can go further okay so I am going to open it up for questions and where we're asked this question don't ask me about the rest of this because this is something that really needs to be done over a call to go deeper into that.
All right so i'm going to unmute everybody and you are live.
How do you know when you think that issue is over and that you're not forming more antibodies as you go along and that's a good question because many times well you should rerun the test so you rerun the test in three to six months.
And you see where it's at now unfortunately the truth is why why do these happen why do I have antibodies to to test you have antibodies to these things the only reason why you'll develop antibodies to a food is because you have damage got.
Period that's the only way you will so if the food stays in inside the intestines it's really outside of the body so you will not create antibodies inside the intestine aluminum it's only when you have a damage got border that these that proteins and peptides of these foods cross that border and that's when your immune system fire.
The immune system fires a reaction to it so you have to remove the source of inflammation that is the foods that you have antibodies against.
In order for your gut to start healing and of course you're doing some other things to help heal your gut through that time too so once you do that and your gut starts to heal then those antibodies will start to calm down because each one of these antibodies have a half life in your blood stream.
And they're all different and there hasn't been studies on very many of them except gluten but so I can't tell you how long it's going to take for those antibodies to dissipate but I've had people where we've had tests that look like this we did we did this again and some of these went down to yellow but then they had some other ones like millet went up to red and it was agreed before what the heck well it's because if you're still your damage got you were so limited on your diet you were eating this.
And because your gut was damaged now you have anybody's in that well don't get alarmed it's just another sign that work or got this damage so now we're going to stay off that for a period of time and this is down to green so we're going to eat a little bit of that because you've got to eat something you understand so you're just played with this to get your gut healed so.
So it's like a seesaw it can be like a seesaw it's all a matter of don't get too bummed that about the food itself the food itself is just a side of the wall damage so we're removing the food that's causing the inflammation other things are going to end up causing inflammation most likely but we got to get the gut healed there's no other way to do.
So a rotation diet is an option yeah it really yes that's why you know I've said for years a rotation diet makes sense to me I think there was a reason why God had things grow in seasons because you're never eating you know one thing all the time now you can go to the grocery store you can buy oranges just about three or 65 days a year.
I don't think we were supposed to eat it that way we're supposed to be changing our diet what is in season having some sort of rotation.
There's a rotation would help yes.
Okay thank you.
This is Thomas I if your immune system is improving like mine I just took a test improve it's improving and I don't really have gut issues does that mean that you know what does that mean.
So did you just do the Cyrix 10.
No I haven't done any of that I haven't really had gut issues but I'm supposed to be off the gluten and the dairy I just took filler blood tests for neutropenia and that's improving good good so yeah so that I guess the question does everybody need to do a test like this the answers no you don't.
You don't you know if if you're if you don't have got symptoms so just let's clarify one thing just because the person doesn't have got symptoms doesn't either have don't have got issues so let's make sure we're we're understanding that so a person can have.
You know rheumatoid arthritis and it's all caused from inflammation that began in the gut so a person could have prostate cancer caught you know as an inflammation of the gut is a major contributor to it so a person may not have any symptoms is still a big part of their problem is started with or a piece of it has to do with inflammation of the gut so let's clarify that.
But if there are other symptoms whatever they're dealing with their prostate cancer and their neutropenia their other blood work is all starting to come back into normal because there's other things they're doing well and if you're happy with the way your health is going well there's no need to necessarily dig any deeper.
But so the person that would want to dig deeper and do this test is if they're unhappy with the way their health is going and I'm saying regardless of what that health issue is.
It can have a strong tie to inflammation in the gut so go back to that gut check video that you all watched in my office and that you all have on your computer that says that you know literally all problems could begin in the gut no matter what it is so that's a piece of it so that's who to want to do this.
Okay, thank you.
Dr. Connors.
Hi it's Lisa Nagle from New Jersey.
I have a question about ozone.
I actually just got four ozone injections in my for my teeth.
So I have two root canals like 15 years ago on the bottom molars.
Every time I do a thermographic image of my dental thyroid there's always heat there the the the doctor of the the biography he says.
You know the thyroid is probably never going to be right because my blood work the thyroid's always off until those teeth are extracted but he did suggest doing ozone like two two rounds this month and two rounds next month.
So my question is is that a way to go or that's just in the meantime.
No, I think that's a great way to go.
So that's exactly the example I was using that ozone really shines with your dealing with biotoxins.
So ozone used did to Lee is can really be wonderful.
Okay, so yeah, I think that's a great idea.
Over getting implants like because I've also been doing the right the dental program.
But still the thermographic image shows up so just today I did the ozone so is this something I should just do every like the dentist said maybe every six months because she muscle tests people.
You know you probably can't do to you know relatively speaking you can't do too much ozone she doing ozone injections.
Yes, I got four today.
Do you have a root canal tooth that she's doing it out or is it just your gums issues her.
You know it's well the two root canals on the bottom one side the other top was a tooth she extracted it's still extracted there I'm wearing up a piece a tooth piece.
And then the other side is the sides of my breast tumor so she did that side.
And she just she did all four quadrants.
So I'm going again next week again so is it okay.
Oh yeah I think it's way okay.
And she might even be under recommending.
So I would if I if I were you I'd ask her does she do the thermography right there to.
Well no that's okay.
So you might want to finish what she's asked to do and say hey can I go do another thermography if it's still really hot there will you continue to do ozone injections.
Oh okay yeah I would say for sure.
Now the thermographer said we have to wait six months after the ozone injections for the thermography to be accurate because he said it could still show like in other words he said do two months rounds of it and then do the thermography like in the fall.
So I was surprised at that well I would yeah I was surprised that too because he hasn't you know asked the thermographer if you'll do it for you a little bit cheaper without sending it in meeting that so one of the reasons why we have to charge what we do for thermography is we send it in to get rent.
So we have done for some other patients as partly because of my morbid curiosity of our what we're doing working let's take some pictures and let's just see we don't have to send them in we'll just do some comparison pictures and see.
And maybe charge you a little bit less for the thermography because he's not said I didn't get rent.
I just don't think you need to wait six months for crying out loud I don't know if I'd agree with that so I would ask to take pictures again just even you know of course they're sticking a needle in you so that's going to be some inflammation there from the needle but after that that's going to calm down within a week or so I would take pictures.
I mean if you were living right here I'd say let's just take some pictures and see what it looks like right after you do it.
Okay, and so now what can I also use to clear out that no became what is a good what should I do today to just.
Well, no of a kid's going to detoxify your pond one pathway and I don't remember what your genetic pond one pathways look like.
I take that pond one supplement so you might want to just bump that up you're taking a couple a day maybe take you know an extra one or two a day.
Okay, do a foot detox do some packs over your liver and you're doing coffee in a most couple times a week right.
No, I'm not.
Oh that's right that's right you're one of those.
No, I just can't do everything and I just I'm in a place.
It's a rug with you girl.
I do the sauna.
Okay, well you're doing sauna so that's going to help you too.
Okay, okay, okay, good.
All right well thank you for that well good.
All right, appreciate it.
Dr Conner's my um thermography that was done in your office came up with some hotspots around my you know jaw teeth or whatever and.
I mentioned that to my dentist when I went in the next time and they they said well.
We don't know what to say because they don't see anything you know they.
I don't know if they even have a good way of detecting inflammation but I'm not I don't have bleeding gums or they don't see any sign of.
Anything to be concerned about so what what is that all mean and where do I go from here.
Yeah, you almost have to go to a biological dentist because if you just take X-rays and if the dentist is rely on an X-rays for.
Of quote unquote infection you have to have a pretty massive infection to be seen on X-ray.
I mean you would be going to the dentist because you have screaming tooth or jaw pain.
And then they take an X-ray and say oh you have an infection.
But to have a bold infection that's visible in X-ray has to be pretty bad.
So the going to a biological dentist like who leases going to they write they understand that.
So they're they're making they're using different tools to assess the patient.
Like the person who leases going to is doing some kinesiology to assess the patient if they have an infection because they don't they can't see it on X-ray.
Now there is a new little CT thing that's a fancy dentist office ham but they're very expensive tools that you can do a CT type scan of your mouth.
But you know they're not that's not cheap and that's radiation.
And that's much more sensitive than a that a plane film X-ray to detect that.
That's where thermography shines we have a local dentist that's a biological dentist here that was super excited when they he found out that we have thermography because that can show an infection faster than anything else can and that's why we put people on that tooth and gum oil a lot.
That's one way to help with the infection now Michelle did a whole video dental care on a zoom call a while back maybe four or five months ago that she could search through the zoom calls and look at though find those two.
And we're actually looking at just the other day I was looking at another product that is beneficial there's a certain straight of probiotic that can be extremely beneficial for infections and I'm trying to find where we can get that the problem is it's the one company that used to carry it.
It's it's a it's a straight of acidophilic cell various the one company that used to carry it.
I had it in a lossage and then they couldn't get it stabilized in the loss and so they pull it off the market so they're still at R and D.
But I'm trying to find a company that has it in a capsule that then we can people have people just open it up and switch it around in their mouth.
That can be helpful and then there's another there's another product that I'm looking at carry to that can be really helpful because I really believe that dental health can can be a major player in many cancers especially breast cancer.
And had a neck and throat and upper body cancers so dealing with that is is important so we're constantly looking for better ways to help people with that all right any other questions.
Dr. Connors is patty and Nebraska hello patty I just wanted to comment about the foot bath I've only had it about eight months and finally able to implement it on a more regular basis and the result I'm seeing is for for the last two weeks I'm actually the lymphoma tumor that's in my left clavicle it's finally shrinking.
Oh yeah that's good news so I just wanted to share that because it's been sitting in my closet and I'm sure others have them sitting in their closets because you can't do everything right Lisa.
You can't do everything and I'll be the first to admit I don't do the foot bath I just don't have time so.
I guess I have to get one I would say I was really I've been really amazed with that and because I'm very strict person about everything as well but it's been the only thing other than rest and it only goes down and up it just hasn't resolved.
And now it's starting to reason so I'm hoping for more to come to keep that wonderful that's really really good news that's great news and maybe I got to start doing it too and maybe it'll force me to sit still for 45 minutes that will tell you it helps me with that part too because then I'm sorry my feet are in the bath I just can't do anything for anyone.
Thank you so much for sharing that and that we will end on that high note so thank you very much make sure you post your questions on Facebook and the person who had this question make sure you call and send me a point with probably with Angie would be the perfect person.
All right and we will see you guys all next week.
Thank you Dr. Connors be well bye bye.